everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends no no
she literally made a new friend
I want you to meet four key he's a spool
yes yeah I know four key is the most
important toy to Bonnie right now we all
have to make sure nothing happens to him
woody we have a situation I am NOT a toy
I was paper soup salad maybe chili and
then the trash but we gotta get worked
up urban
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boy what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff would he always come in
to the rescue body needs 40 woody who
needs a kids room when you can have all
of this Wow
woody are we going to Barney we have to
find the total e2 but what would he do
jump out of a moving vehicle let's go
hey you gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can be
good you can't teach this old toy new
tricks
you'd be surprised Bonnie we're coming
home for you
on my way whatever windy
kids lose their choice every day I was
made to help the child I remember it
being this hard buddy
somebody's whispering in your ear
[Music]